good day to all of you welcome back to
the third session on the promise and
peril of globalization we've in our
first I guess it was a preliminary
session zero section I think probably
would be good to call that one we've
sketched the doug has sketched a bit
historical developments of which
globalization is apart and developments
leading to globalization and then the
next session with Tony Blair we talked
about the stakes in getting it right
about faith in global is er why does
this thing matter at all now we direct
our attention primarily to globalization
and examine peril and promise of
globalization then we'll shift attention
to religions examine transformations of
faith in n secularization thesis and
then we'll try to look at interrelation
between the two around the set of
particular issues so that's roughly the
outline of the whole course and we are
at the very beginning of it now promise
and peril of globalization is the title
for us for us today and it has a kind of
ambivalent globalization has kind of
ambivalent character what I want to do
here being being a theologian is to pick
up of some of the things that we've been
discussing about significance of paid
and then talk about promise and peril of
faiths because there's also the kind of
deep ambivalence of faiths which was
noted on the sidelines but nonetheless
which is very prominent and important
piece in our discussions as we are
leading them so I don't need to repeat
too much more about the significance of
fades it's contested that the issue is
contestant to what degree fates are
significant and if you come from the
tradition say of Karl Marx then you or
somebody like Friedrich Nietzsche you'll
think of faith is kind of epi phenomenal
their derivative they basically don't
call
ultimately anything but there are the
consequences of something then you'll
have a certain view of the significance
of of fate but and that's kind of one
general position if one if one takes but
also more imperative grounds people
people have always asked me because I
come from former Yugoslavia they want to
figure out what's happening there and so
that the question always ends up being
well what is it it was it about economy
was it about politics was it about land
I was it about religion and basically I
said all of the above and I have coined
in these conversations a little phrase
which said all mono causal explanations
are suspect especially if you have
complex event of these of this sword as
eruption of violence in former
Yugoslavia let's not try to reduce it to
a single cause so there may be multiple
causes at work we're interested or at
least aspect of interest of ours is here
significance of fades in some of those
events for ill and for good which takes
me then to the question of promise and
peril of a faith so we can grant for the
sake of the argument that fades are
significant but then how do they
function how do these states function
and there are definite disagreements on
that question and there are definite
ambivalences also of the role of faith a
disagreement some consider faiths
obviously as a force for good others
consider faiths as a significant hope
force for for ill in the world today
believers clearly mostly would argue
that fades are somehow force for good at
least if you look at the heart of the
faith some human is also if they're not
relatively strong atheists might agree
also that fades in a not quite adequate
way express some of the fundamental
inspirations of human beings moral codes
that and are able to motivate people to
follow those
so they can see possibly say this force
of good others of course what critics
would claim the faith is a force force
for real fates are irrational and
irrationality by its very nature is a
force for for ill and critics my art
might argue also that fades are by their
very nature violent and there are such
accounts of religion which for instance
would suggest that the very heart at the
heart of all faiths lies something like
the combat myth and that combat myth
structures how the faith functions as a
whole in the world and it's not been an
accident than in situations of conflict
fades end up generating or reinforcing
at least a violent no so so there's
these disagreements but there's also the
ambivalence of the faith itself alright
even those who see that fates are their
heart a force for good agree that fades
sometimes maybe even often when as their
practice concretely function for ill
right so that they are forces for good
and they are at the same time forces of
ill for ill as concretely practice as
lived fades and in this class we will be
primarily interested in this concrete
side of fades in lived side of fades
rather than simply in theoretical
constructs about fades or debates about
rationality of faiths or anything of
that sort so there's this ambivalence of
faith as concretely practiced but
there's also second kind of ambivalence
I think which is very very interesting
to to note it stems from the fact that
fates themselves are of such character
that they offer perspectives from which
to judge certain actions as good or ill
right they are overarching
interpretations of life therefore there
are vantage points of assessing behavior
so a particular act in particular cause
may look either as good salad
or not depending on the concrete shape
of faith that one takes as a standpoint
for evaluating so for 911 for instance
it matters profoundly whether you share
bin Laden's religious convictions and
consider all who disagree with you if
there are Muslims as apostates if there
are non-muslims as infidels it matters
very much for deciding whether the
attack on World Trade Center is to be
described as deplorable violence or is
to be described as part of just struggle
right it's perspective of judgment and
for instance we had the other cases
Jubilee right well it may matter I'm not
sure whether it really does but it may
matter in how you assess this whether
you are a person's person guided solely
by utilitarian principles or if you
believe that we should feed the poor
irrespective of the consequences of that
action for future economic development
and so forth right it may depend on your
position how you evaluate the role of
religion in this case and there are some
I think it's part of our our case study
right some people who say well all these
good mind that people right who are
doing wrecking havoc on things by trying
to improve improve the world right if
you're a person of faith you might have
a quite different perspective on that
and there's a debate bump about this I
think it's also important as we think
about faith and this there there
ambivalence is to note that at least the
way we are using the term fades that is
not as a kind of individual convictions
not as kind of private spirituality but
as part of faith traditions um but it
but as a kind of overarching
interpretations of life that guide human
behavior as part of the large faith
traditions if you look at these then you
see that some of these ambivalences and
disagreements are embedded in fades
themselves one way to look at faith is
to see them as centuries-long sometimes
extended
visions of arguments about the goods
which constituted that faith often
people who look in fates of the outside
they see kind of a monolithic structure
pronouncements of somebody from the cave
or somebody from Vatican or from from
wherever else and that seems to kind of
set in stone what faith is but if you
look more carefully you see centuries
indeed long traditions of debate how
faith should be understood and I think I
mentioned in this class and it is a
phrase of David Martin who was supposed
to be with us sociologist from school
for economic emeritus now along the
School of Economics who talks about
fates having repertoires where they take
certain elements are played up other
elements are pushed into the into the
background and that's part and parcel of
the long argument within those faith
tradition so that each faith develops
over time it has a variety of
expressions depending on larger cultural
in their environment and the specific
conditions under which faith live shape
the forms of arguments and positions of
faith people people take so that each
faith is then in turn internally
differentiated in itself and constitutes
a tradition of debate so that much on
the promise and peril of faiths they
obviously have perils those are visible
very clearly some of us think that they
also have certain promise but that's a
very much contestant in debatable issue
now theme for today is a promise and
peril of globalization and what I intend
to do is simply highlight some of the
issues from the readings and then let
professor ray and our guests in again
and Shapiro to continue discussing these
these these themes procedure for today
is going to be as always when we have
guests Tony Blair is not a guest when we
have guests in classroom that we have
roughly
each of us teachers professor array and
myself make 15 minutes comments then
guests comes from another 15 minutes and
then about 20 minutes of discussion and
then the guests will be taken away from
you whisked away so you can barrage him
or her with questions anymore but the
the other flip side of this is if you're
interested in pursuing questions
specifically to to our guest 20 minutes
is your chance and I hope that in the
interest of time all of us would think
carefully how we formulate our question
be questions be brief as we formulate
and then run with thing okay promise and
peril of globalization well there's
certain kind of ambivalence to
globalization itself and you can see how
these have been analyzed in the texts
that we have read for for today it's
interesting also that some of the texts
speak of multiple globalization's almost
right they use phrases like economic
globalization cultural globalization I
take it that's a short right short for
economic aspects of globalization
because if you take those is kind of
distinct you will miss the deep
interrelationship between all of all of
these economic aspect of globalization
central issue that was highlighted was
the relationship between wealth and
poverty in ambiguity around that and the
one hand globalization seems to lift
people out of poverty but then the
question becomes the critics of
globalization can he do so while
respecting equality and some of the
significant social norms of justice
environment was an issue that was
highlighted right on the one hand it
creates global environmental awareness
but on the other hand partly that
awareness was created by the damage that
was done to the environment cultural
aspects of globalization I think were
elements that are have been highlighted
earlier in our readings was were the
questions of group identity
questions of relationship between
homogenizing tendencies at kind of
heterogeneous I know mmm it's a sketchy
word right differentiating right a
partner I uses that I think but I'm not
quite sure whether it was really really
work so and we've dealt bit with this it
was in the backdrop of Huntington
reading and so forth I think one of the
things that hasn't been discussed so
much and becomes first time in our
reading and it's bears I think some
reflection upon and that is the question
of cultural reproduction dear called
that text toward the end of a Padres
piece where he asked the question so so
that globalization creates settings
characterized one by high pace of change
right so over time the change happens in
accelerated accelerated way of change
but also environments saturated with
diversity and then he asked the question
but how do you form cultural habits
stable cultural habits right internalize
discipline character trades a kind of
internalization of values and so forth
right able to sustain people in a
complex and rapidly changing cultural
environment I think that's a very
interesting question question to ask and
I think it's connected also where the
main topic of our seminar is a whole
relationship between faiths and
globalization because often just because
globalization processes aren't able to
form stable kind of sustainable cultural
trades faiths come in and then provide
the framework for people from which they
can stand as they face cultural change
and then finally and I think that's
going to lead into what Professor
Shapiro is going to speak is a political
aspects of globalization on the one hand
interest in creation of global
institutions and on the other hand the
relationship between these
global institutions and national
governments their relative strength
their ability both ability to express
the will of the people ability to
guarantee security to the people and in
some of the texts that we've read their
ability to provide safety networks
especially for those who suffer under
the consequences of the parents of
globalization that was some of the
issues I think that was that were raised
in terms of promise and peril of
globalization that's all I have to say
for today and I give the floor to
Professor ring